hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're
starting our coverage of the 2017
champion showdown held in st. louis
missouri i'm gonna give a quick intro
into how the showdown is structured and
then we'll look at one of the matches
from day one there's eight competitors
and each competitor is matched up
against one individual opponent I'll go
and give you the matchups right now
Nakamura will be faced off against Opel
of Fabiana Kawana against Alexander
Greece shook Wesley Silver's linear
Dominguez and Magnus cross and vs.
England and those are going to be their
opponents the entire format they're
gonna play 30 games against their
opponent over a four-day stretch the
first three matchups I mentioned will
play from Thursday to Sunday and Magnus
Carlsen will kick off on Saturday and
Carlsen and Bingley and will play from
Saturday through Tuesday we'll have as
much coverage as possible but playing 30
games against each of your opponent or
against your individual opponent means
you're gonna have to play some pretty
quick matches instead of these four hour
marathon sessions they're gonna be
playing rapid and blitz chess 30 games
in total ten games of rapid chess rapid
just means anywhere from 10 to 60
minutes and 20 games of blitz chess
meaning games of less than 10 minutes
this is a format very different than
others where there's no time increment
added after you play there's also no
delay meaning your clock is going to
start immediately when it is your turn
on day one you'll be playing your
opponent for games of 30 minute
increments Medina you have 30 total
minutes for the game on day two you'll
be playing six games of twenty minutes
day three eight games of ten minutes and
on the last day twelve games of
five-minute blitz chess at the end of
that there's different points awarded
for wins on each of the days at the end
of four days if you have the most points
you will win $60,000 if you lose you
will win
$40,000 if there's a tie they will split
that so you're just playing one opponent
doesn't matter if you win every single
game you're not gonna win any more or
less than someone else that wins their
heads that match up against their
opponent so you really get to get a good
sense
of what your opponent is trying to do
over time and as you can imagine as
things progress and maybe one person is
down a few wins you start to see more
aggression and some lines that maybe if
they were ahead or tied they may not go
down those but things get pretty crazy
once we get into some of the later rapid
and especially the Blitz game so that is
the format that we will be going over
over the next week we'll try to have as
much analysis as possible so you guys
can see as much of the coverage the
first game we're going to be looking at
is between the Cuban Grandmaster Linna
Dominguez and the American Wesley so one
of the top players in the world
currently this is the fourth game on day
one the first three games they played
were all a draw and while you don't have
to win any of the game since you play 30
in total both sides looking to in day
one on a strong note so we're going to
get started white plays pawn e4 West's
so continues pond e5 Knight f3 knight c6
Bishop b5 the right Lopez and the
defense of the Berlin defense Knight to
f6 some people refer to this as the
Berlin Wall and this mirrors a lot of
the games they played up into this point
from games 1 through 3 as well as a lot
of the other competitors against their
opponents playing the Berlin defense and
if you've been following chess
tournaments that I've covered over the
past few years this tends to be one of
the most popular defenses that we see
for players starting with pawn to to e4
straight getting into the right Lopez
and then the Berlin defense a lot of
ways that white can't continue he can
castle on the king's head if he wants to
or decide to play more of a quiet pawn
to d3 solidifying his pawn chain he does
have his lights for a bishop outside
this pawn chain so he can go and
solidify give his dark squared bishop
involved give his Knight involved castle
on the Kings side have a safe game don't
have to get into anything too crazy
right now black plays a bishop down here
c5 and then Knight to c3 and this is
probably what I would consider a safe
play he does have the option of Bishop
to e3 and so if Wesley so now decides to
exchange you can recapture though he
does have a double pawn here
this is gonna be fine he's controlling
in the center of the board and it's
gonna be easy for him to exchange at
some point and no longer have a doubled
up pawn structure here on the e-file
this also opens up you know if there's
pawn to d6 castle on the kingside this
is rook here on f1 is a very aggressive
square it's a semi-open file can really
start to attack the king side of the
board but this does open up some risk
for white he has a weakened king side
since there's not an extra pawn in front
of him and he does have to maneuver to
make sure that he gets the pawn away
from the the double pawn structure here
on the e-file so all things considered
right now I decides to play Knight to c3
I would imagine as we progress into some
later blitz gains that the you know on
day 3 and 4 we will see more aggressive
lines like a Bishop to e3
also if the mingoes was down games I
think he would try to play more
aggressive lines with it being tied
right now doesn't need to do anything
too crazy so Knight to c3 Castle on the
kingside Bishop takes on c6 pawn
recaptures on c6 pawn to h3 so both
sides playing what I would consider
normal main book lines Knight can't come
down to G for right now so stopping that
rook to e8 and then Bishop to e3 not a
lot of great squares for the bishop
could come to could come up here to g5
if we wanted to pin down the knight but
decides to first go ahead and say hey
you know Wesley so do you want to
exchange material right here if he does
exchange you could also see the B Nia's
castle on the Queen side and have some
open files for both of his works to
attack on the King side whistling so
decides that's not the path he wants to
go down he's already committed to castle
on one side of the board and so if you
have this exchange it tends to favor
some aggression from white so he decides
to bring his bishop back here to d6 he
has the double Bishop wants to hold on
to that advantage right now Knight back
here to e2 interesting move to go ahead
and start bringing your knight over to
the King side of the board but entire
strategies are changing just on simple
moves right here so he would have played
completely different if there was an
exchange but with the bishop coming back
to d6 decides let's go ahead
by night over to the Kings side of the
board pawn to c5 Knight here to g3 and
then pawn a5 says okay if you're gonna
start maneuvering to the Kings side I'm
gonna start attacking the Queen side at
the board y decides to go ahead and stop
that attack on the Queen side pawns a
for when you're probably doing this a
lot in your own games they play pawn h5
on the King side pawn a5 on the Queen
side you don't want them to push you any
further
it just makes life difficult you're
trying to develop your your pawns or
your pieces so pawn a for stopping that
Knight here to d7 allowing them a few
options do you come to be 8 and then c6
he could come f8 and then e 6 to
maneuver control the center of the board
and then up here f5 and then he chooses
to go with the Knights of f8 path not
down here d2 and both sides really just
maneuvering their Knights around the
center of the board trying to get to a
better position based on how their pawn
structures are set up and this is giving
Wesley so an option here he has the the
double pawns here on the C file if he
wanted to exchange his bishop he could
and not have to worry about that double
pawns here but decides he wants to hold
on to his double bishops and not give
that away and this particular spot
dominguez feel something on the board
that he wants to take advantage of and
this is probably the the place where you
know black has the most passive setup on
the board both of his bishops are on the
eighth-ranked right now his knight on
the board really isn't doing a ton by
itself here and he has a very active
position with both of his Knights in the
center Bishop here on e3 he can get his
Queen and bottom to the game very easily
so he decides to go ahead and play pawn
to g4 very aggressive starting to attack
the King side of the board his
opponent's already blinked and then he's
castled on one side of the board so it's
gonna be very easy for Dominguez to
castle on the Queen side start to throw
everything he wants at the King side of
the board his opponent doesn't know
where White's going to castle he still
has different options so if Wesley so
decided to throw everything at the Queen
side of the board he could still castle
on the King so I won't be as protected
but he figures he's playing the white
pieces he has animators he wants to push
push that as much as possible you
some of his other options he plays
Bishop 2d - maybe now night down here d4
that's one of the reasons you play
Knight to e6 and then you take there's a
recapture maybe you want to take the
knight up here on a the pawn here on a5
your Bishop is protecting that part of
the reason we brought the bishop back
here - 2 D - maybe Queen down here h4
you castle it just gets tricky as far as
your opponent maybe have a perpetual
check here some of the safer options
don't tend to end up in the in the spot
that Dominguez probably wanted to get to
so he decides his best route is to play
pawn to g4 and be as aggressive as
possible Wesley so responds with Knight
down here to d4 pawn up c3 forcing the
knight to move Knight takes back here on
f5 and if you say well why doesn't the
knight take it it's probably worse for
the night to take care on d4 because
then the pawns gonna take this pawn here
on d4 is just putting so much pressure
on the opponent black is really
controlling the center of the board the
bishops forced to move now pawn to b6
can get the light squared bishop
involved into the center of the board I
think this is going to be worse for
white to decide so let's not deal with
that instead let's go ahead and try to
kick that night away after he does that
now pawn takes on f5 and this kind of
signals in my mind that if he's opening
up the King side of the board he's
really looking to castle on the Queen
side really start to control the king
side of the board with his rooks on
these semi open files pawn to c6 Queen
here - a c2 a pawn down here b5 so
knowing that white could be castling on
the Queen side Wesley so starts to throw
everything he can at the Queen side of
the board Knight comes back here to d2
pawn g6
interesting move from Wesley so saying
I'm okay stopping some of your attack
even if it weakens my King side of the
board and then the pawn takes here on g6
I don't think white has to take here he
has some other options he could castle
on the Queen side of the board right
away he could play Knight to f3 I don't
really think that his opponent
going to take here with f5 because you
could castle on the King said you could
take back right away you could start
with the check here on g1 this really
opens up the door for an attack so I
think you can save the pawn takes on g6
and develop some other pieces to give
you a better spot but Dominguez decides
I'm gonna go ahead and capture this
material right here we see the recapture
and then castle on the Queen side
exactly as we expected now the pawn
takes on a 4 and then up here to c4
could decide to go ahead and take it
right away
but says you know what I'm gonna get
this material back my pony can't really
hold on to that material so this is fine
I'm gonna go ahead and play first Knight
to c4 once they so plays pawn to a3 he
recognizes that this pawn is going to
fall so all he wants to do is try to get
an isolated pawn over here and not allow
his opponent to have a better pawn
structure so sometimes if you are going
to lose material it's best just to see
if you can put a damper in your
opponent's plants that's what he does
with pawn to a3 work over here to b8
also allowing him the opportunity to
have control of this B file and so this
ends up giving Wesley so something back
for that exchange but Wesley so really
needs to be aggressive he has all of his
material on the eighth-ranked Dominguez
has you know a better position as far as
his material in the stern of the board
and where he is attacking so right now I
would give a slight advantage to
Dominguez pawn up here h4 says right now
I gotta throw everything at the King
side of the board
I've castle on the Queen side you're
gonna start to tack on the Queen side
and my best option is the King side
Bishop down here g4 attacking the rook
rook to g1 probably what her white
wanted to go anyway Bishop back h5 and
this really puts a stop to a lot of what
white wanted to do he'd have to bring
his knight over here to really kick this
bishop off this darks for a bishops not
gonna be kicking it off so great little
square for Wesley so to stop an attack
rook here to g3
Bishop down here to e7 attacking the
pawn this really just keeps
the rook here on h1 from doing too much
as far as going away it has to protect
that Bishop to g5 says hey let's
exchange if you want to Weston so he's
not having any of that pawn to f6 Bishop
comes back here to e3 King age 7 rook
here to g1 Black's just making sure that
his king is not on the same file that
his opponent is just doubling up all of
his rooks and his material on a queen
here to d7 punt up here to f4 rook to d8
so both sides really just maneuvering
around the board trying to find the best
position that both sides can really
start to attack their opponents a bishop
down here to d2 it had some other
options if you wanted to try pawn takes
on e5 this does open up some of the
board state but asides instead to go
ahead and play Bishop down here to d2
pawn takes on e4
now that Bishop recaptures but a rook
here to be 7 and then Queen over here to
g2 so throwing everything he can over on
the King side of the board you know he
had material that he could have even
taken Knight takes on a5 if he wants to
rook down here a b5 gonna be pretty easy
just rook or Knight back here to c4 but
decides you know what there's such a big
attack going on on the King side of the
board I'm gonna go and play Queen to g2
let's do so plays rook to g8 recognizing
a strong attack is starting on the King
side wants to protect that Queen to h3
just says hey if you want to exchange
Queens on board I'm fine with that
there's an exchange rook takes on h3 so
as soon as Queen comes off the board you
start to see both sides recognizing
their King's really become a valuable
asset in the game and you really don't
want them to be on the outskirts of the
game you want them to be in the center
they control a lot of the board it does
become somewhat difficult when your
opponent's have double bishops both of
their rooks that they're connected and
there's open files they can start to
attack so both sides are gonna be
looking at ways that they can get their
King without getting into a strong
attack pawn to a full
or says hey you were attacking it with
unite you didn't take it before so I'm
gonna try to hold on to that material
right now this does also open up the
ability for the rook to come down to b3
if it wants to because the outpost from
the pawn here on a4 King to g7 rook here
to g3 just doubling up on the semi-open
file on the G file King here f7 just
centralizing Knight to a5 attacking the
rook rook here to b6 Knight back here to
see for both sides doing a good job in
this rapid game with only 30 minutes
they've both played solid chess both put
their opponents in some situations where
they can make mistakes and both sides
are really making the best decisions
along the way few things you know that
they could have maneuvered where I gave
them slightly better position but these
guys have prepared for this tournament
for months now and so there's a good
reason why they're playing what they're
doing and they also have scattering
reports on their opponent's they know
what their opponents like to do and so
what we're seeing some great chess which
is always exciting in these fast games
to see how their minds works they don't
have hours to think about these
different moves they're doing it
sometimes in a matter of seconds rook
back here to b7 since it's no longer
attack bishop up here d6 says yeah I'll
go ahead and exchange if you want to
what's the so decides I'm not ready to
do that right away we do see an exchange
with the bishops right now and I think
that's good for for white it doesn't
have to worry about the the two bishops
on board but I would say getting into
the in game Wesley so still has the
better minor piece Knights usually best
if there's pawns on one side of the
board cuz he can really just control all
that but if there's pawns all over
bishops tend to do better because they
can control all of the aboard all of the
board they can get there very very
quickly you know White's perspective you
know he wants to make sure that he
doesn't have all of his pawns in
material on light squares if his
materials not on light squares this
light square bishop tends to not do too
she can block off some of the squares
that he can go to but as far as
attacking the pieces doesn't have to
worry about that rook here to f1 start a
new attack these rooks are kind of a
nuisance for black to have to worry
about his bishops tied down here right
now the king or the rooks are gonna have
to be dealing with that so White's being
more aggressive I would say in Black's
right now just has to be defensive rook
to e3 says if he wants to push forward
in the center of the board we're go over
here to b8 since it's no longer
attacking as much decides this is this
may be my only opportunity to start to
double down and start to attack on the
King said or the Queen side of the board
for white you can see how valuable this
night here on c4 is it stops a lot of
the squares that black would want to go
to on his own side of the board but as
well if the rook wants to come down to
2b - he can't even though he's doubled
up because the Knights as well as the
rook here on the first rank stopping the
rook coming down here to b1 so white
doing a good job stopping a lot of
attacks that black would want to do and
it's not easy for black to kick this
night off yes it is on the lights
Courtney has the LightSquared Bishop but
how does he easily get this light square
Bishop over there to kick that off
doesn't do it very easily rook here to
g1 Knight here to d7 we do see some
repetition and moves but rook here to g3
making sure there's not threefold
repetition doesn't want to have a drawl
here rook here - b7 comes back and we do
see that repeat once but then we decide
to change that up so there's no draw
rook here to be one says let's exchange
on board if you want to that's exactly
what we see happen once he so decides
this is my best opportunity to get this
Bishop down here to d1 and so that's
exactly what happens King here c1 Bishop
up here
b3 says okay now I can get this night
off the board if I want to are on the
off the square here on c4 Knight back
here d2 attacking the bishop pawn down
here c4 just extending the pressure on
his opponent decided to go ahead and
take that rook over here - b7 says yeah
you're up upon the material but it's a
double
I think I can get that back so I'm not
too worried about it right now I'm gonna
go and bring my work over here to b7 now
white decides to go ahead and start to
force blacks hand a little bit and
attack his pawns over here on the
kingside the board rook here to g3 says
I'm gonna attack your pawn on a g6 rook
over here 287 so yeah it forces his hand
a little bit says I'm gonna attack your
pawn if you want to take mine I'll take
yours as well
Knight here to f3 so positioning
recognizing that stuffs about to happen
on the kingside not too worried about
this pawn as we said before it's gonna
be difficult to hold on to the double
pawns just says hey I'll give you that
pawn if you want to I want to start to
attack this King side of the board
protect my pawn first and foremost here
on h4 Bishop takes on c4 as expected
now the rook takes on g6 but then we see
an interesting move of Bishop to d3 and
really we needed a king to f7 that
probably makes the most sense of forcing
the rook back here
I still like White's position either way
I think this entire exchange on how it
went down is better for white but you
have to play the King to f7 here the
problem is after Bishop to d3 you're not
just gonna get this material back it's
not that easy white has to move Knight
to g5 and this is a huge huge dagger for
King the king and the rook here on 87
the pawn can't recapture because it's
being pinned down by the rook here on g6
I move Wesley so no doubt if he had more
time would fine but in a rapid game he
just didn't see this and immediately
after this move he was forced to resign
so great game
Dominguez I would consider this a huge
upset Wesley so being one of the top
players in the world right now and it's
just been on its hair the past a year
and a half
pretty much beating everyone in his way
Wesley so Falls to Dominguez
and so after four games Dominguez goes
into day two with a a game in hand so be
looking to can
in you that run as they play some more
rapid games on a day-to so a lot of
exciting chess going on for day two we
will be covering a couple games day one
didn't want to have an overview so
you're familiar with how the tournament
starts but we will be having multiple
games as far as coverage goes so be sure
and check back but thank you everyone
for watching and I'll see you in the
next video